-Our first guest tonight is
a very funny actor you know
from movies like "This Is 40,"
"Anchorman," and "Clueless."
He returns to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania,"
which premieres in theaters
and IMAX February 17th.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend Paul Rudd,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Thanks, Seth.
Thank you, Seth.
-I'm so happy to see you.
-It's great to see you.
-You are riding high
for a lot of reasons.
One, movie coming out.
More importantly,
for a guy like me,
your Kansas City Chiefs,
Super Bowl champions.
Congratulations.
-Yeah. Thank you very much.
-You got to be at the game.
-I went.
-Fantastic.
-Oh, my gosh.
What a -- What a whirlwind
that experience is.
And it's just thrilling,
you know, when your team wins.
Especially I've been a fan
for a long, long time.
So this is kind of
a new experience.
-And you had your son, Jack,
with you.
And that must make it
extra special,
because, again, this is
something that you --
he would not be a football fan
if it wasn't --
or he wouldn't be a Chiefs fan
if it wasn't for you.
-Right, 'cause I guess he
started kind of rooting for them
when he was about 6 or so.
-Yeah.
-He's 18 now, and it's true.
Like, the best thing
is to be able
to kind of share this
with your kid.
So, yeah, it was just --
it was awesome.
-So they won in 2020
when they won.
That was, you know,
a big deal for,
I mean, again,
you as well as Jack,
but it must have been
such a cool moment to share
as a father and a son.
-It was.
That whole run
really was just massive,
and it started this whole thing.
And it was such a nice feeling,
because, you know, in that year,
in the first playoff game,
the Chiefs were down by
24 points against the Texans.
And it really was the first time
I did kind of have this,
"Why do I do this?"
My son was so despondent.
He was so sad,
just kind of walking around.
Went into another room.
-Yeah.
-And I really had kind of that
by myself.
I was really upset and mad.
'Cause I thought, this is not --
this is not worth it.
It's just not worth
putting yourself
through this kind of despair.
I feel like -- I know all Eagles
fans are feeling this right now.
I know all fans of other teams
are feeling this right now.
-But I feel like -- So this is
a thing that happened to me
that you did to Jack, right,
which is Jack's also
never lived in Kansas City.
-No. Never in his life,
and he's a die-hard Chiefs fan.
-And I'm the same way.
Like, I'm a huge
Pittsburgh Steelers fan
because of my dad.
He fully just did it to me.
I remember the same thing
in my teens
when things were going bad
for the Steelers.
I'd be so upset,
and my dad would say,
"Look, it's not that important."
I'm like,
"You taught me to care!"
-It's the truth. It's like
why do we do this to them?
-I wonder, how does your wife
feel about it?
Because that's the other thing,
is my wife,
who's watched me go through
the roller coaster,
has basically said, like,
"I don't know if I'm cool
with like two more of these
in the house."
-It might be three.
My daughter is real young,
and she watched the game,
and she wrote "Chiefs Kingdom"
in pen on her arms.
And she was -- she loves --
She goes, "I want
a Kadarius Toney jersey."
She's young, but she is also
really into it.
I know, why we brought this
into the house.
It's like adopting a dog and --
-Like a super-old dog.
-A super-old dog.
This is --
You're just bringing --
We're inviting in
disappointment.
[ Laughter ]
-"We want a puppy."
"Well, I got good news
and mostly bad news."
-"This is not --
The time that we're
going to have with him
is going to be very special."
-Yeah.
-"But it's going to be..."
-Very, very short.
-"...short," yeah.
-Alright, so I want
to ask about something.
Right around Christmas,
we do this thing called
"Day Drinking" on the show.
And I was doing it with Lizzo,
and your name came up.
-I saw it.
-Yeah.
And again, it must have been
very exciting,
because Lizzo, let me tell you,
one of the most charming
human beings.
I don't know if you've been
lucky enough to meet her.
-I've never met her.
I watched --
I mean, I watched.
It was on the show.
And when I heard Lizzo
say my name, I was like...
I got all excited.
By the way, it's a weird thing
when you're not expecting
to hear that and you hear it.
And that segment was hilarious,
by the way.
That whole -- Every time
you do it, it's so funny.
-She really did
sort of raise the bar.
I keep telling people
she's so deeply funny.
Even while, like, inebriated,
she, like, talks like
a comedy writer.
-So funny, so charming.
Yeah, it was great.
-She also -- I've told this a
few times, but the great thing,
to bring it back to my dad,
you know,
one of her catchphrases
is "Bye, bitch."
-Right.
-And we left a message --
we left a voicemail for my dad,
and she said --
she ended it by saying,
"Bye, bitch."
-Yeah.
-Then independent of me,
she got my dad's information
and sent him flowers
with a note that said,
"I'm sorry
I called you a bitch."
[ Laughter ]
And my brother and I
call him a bitch all the time.
We've never apologized.
-You owe him a lot of flowers.
-Yeah, we owe him
a lot of flowers.
"You made us root for
the Steelers, you bitch."
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, but the reason
your name came up
is one of our writers walked
out, and he was wearing a mask,
and Lizzo -- and again,
she'd had a few drinks.
She thought it was Paul Rudd.
She thought it was you.
So the writer's here today,
but first I want to show
the first half of the clip,
and then we're gonna bring out
the writer, Seth Reiss.
So here's Lizzo noticing
our writer the first time.
-Ohh, I'm calm now.
-Alright, let's bring him over.
-Paul [bleep] Rudd!
Paul Rudd!
-Hey, Lizzo,
I know the real reason
you're breaking up with me
is that you met famous
Hollywood actor Paul Rudd,
who's now gonna
take his mask off,
and I want you to react to it
in real time.
-[Bleep]
-Alright, so now we're gonna
bring out the writer.
And we're gonna let you guys
decide, was Lizzo crazy?
[ Laughter, cheering ]
Alright, you know what?
Not -- Not --
Not as bad as I thought.
I owe an apology to Lizzo.
But now this is
the really exciting part, guys.
'Cause again, I think
you're agreeing with Lizzo.
This is not too far afield,
until you see the rest
of the face.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of other stuff can happen.
-This better not be --
This better --
Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't even look.
-I need a tissue.
I need a tissue, please.
No, here's the thing.
You don't look anything
like [bleep] Paul Rudd.
[ Laughter ]
-There we go.
Let's see both faces.
There we go.
Paul and Seth Reiss,
brothers from another mother.
-Thank you so much.
-It's like looking in a mirror.
-It's like looking in a mirror!
-Thank you so much.
-And look at these two.
Two snowflakes can be alike.
We'll be right back with more
from Paul Rudd, everybody.